on va se brancher sur le branchement des
diagnostics de ce véhicule là il y a
deux ans le ca a amené une enquête
les spécialistes ont analysé le niveau
de pollution de 511 voitures des modèles
qui avait plus de huit ans pour se rend
compte que ya à peu près le tiers donc
31 % des véhicules qui circulent sur les
routes du québec et qui ont plus de huit
ans qui ne passeraient pas un test
d'inspection environnementale au québec
plus du tiers des véhicules de promenade
en circulation ont plus de huit ans
l'échantillon pris par le ca à reflète
la réalité du parc automobile québécois
ça veut dire que plus d'une voiture sur
dix ne respectent pas les normes
environnementales plus de 500 mille
véhicules qui polluent plus qui
consomment beaucoup plus de sens qu'on
pouvait avoir une sur consommation
d'essence moyenne qui est assez
conservatrice la de 15% donc ces cinq
dollars par plein ses 800 $ au bout 3-1
ceci si l'essence les prix de l'essence
ne s'envolent pas aux etats unis le
département de l'énergie estime qu'une
voiture mal entretenu peut consommer
jusqu'à 40% de plus d'essence et maîtres
toutes sortes de polluants dans
l'atmosphère
tout ce qui émane d'une voiture à
essence d'une voiture et diesel c'est du
vieux sud asa du dioxyde de souffre de
l'ozone départ ce qu'il fait nul trafic
lorsqu'on laisse pire ça ça vient
toucher tout notre système pas seulement
les poumons
on attend toujours par les asthmatiques
mais ça vaut beaucoup plus loin que ça
pour le dr yves la pollution des
voitures mal entretenus et carrément un
problème de santé publique
mais l'apport 2019 de santé canada donc
l'organisme plus officiel que vous
pouvez imaginer dit que ses 117
milliards de dollars de soins de santé
au canada pour la mortalité on parle de
quelque chose comme environ il ya une
fourchette de 15 à 20 mille décès
annuels excédentaire dû à la personne
parce qu'au canada
ça fait 25 ans qu'andré bélisle 1000 est
en faveur d'un programme d'inspection
pour s'assurer que les voitures en
circulation respectent les normes
environnementales
mais on illumine la fois les véhicules
thermiques d'ici à demain matin ou la
fin de l'année 2020 et l'a1
on va vivre avec depuis pour encore
longtemps et ça fait long
autant que le programme le programme
devait être en place en mai 2002 aux
états unis de la californie publiée au
jo zillions des programmes d'inspection
obligatoire depuis les années soixante
dix donc on est complètement dans mon
dos allieri mmo kazakhs stay on
programme d'inspection depuis 16 ans
l'annoncé laquelle nous vous convions
aujourd'hui marque une étape importante
dans l'acheminement d'un projet qui nous
tient particulièrement à coeur
en 2011 andré bélisle était debout aux
côtés de pierre arcand alors ministre de
l'environnement lorsque québec a tenté
de mettre en place un programme
d'inspection des véhicules mais le
projet est mort au feuilleton
et je pense entre autres aux mines et
certains qui nous a demandé de l'aider à
deux reprises il a tenté d'aller de
l'avant mais on attend on a essayé de
convaincre les gens que c'était pas une
bonne idée que ça coûterait cher aux
contribuables aux pauvres au monde
ben c'est exactement contre le véhicule
qui marche mal coûte cher la garde des
sceaux la route qui consomment plus donc
programme d'inspection aurait permis de
faire des économies
une politique de deux pays du
tiers-monde de prêtres capable d'aller
de l'avant et de baisser
significativement non mortalité notre
pollution notre émission de grs paraît
simple système d'inspection des
véhicules symptômes est un droit civil
est essentielle
puis module devez mais l'idée d'un
programme d'inspection systématique des
voitures ne fait pas l'unanimité larnack
ce fait au départ dans les inspections
selon george iny un programme
d'inspection peut être utile les
premières années le temps de repérer les
véhicules les plus polluants
mais après un certain temps les
inspections de vienne selon lui inutile
c'est en partie pourquoi l'ontario a
cessé l'inspection obligatoire si on
inspecte sans voiture prend à trouver 3
qui polluent puis on n'en aurait pas
qu'un sur trois à peu près ça à la fin
des programmes à vancouver
en ontario c'est par efficace et ce sont
les automobilistes les moins fortunés
qui risque d'en payer le prix
ce que c'est à québec souhaite c'est de
surtout de ne pas en ajouter au fardeau
à des automobilistes
le ca a propose d'utiliser l'argent de
ce qu'on appelait le fonds vert pour
réduire les coûts d'entretien et
encourager les gens à prendre soin de
leur véhicule
l'idée qui plaît au docteur rives ya des
subsides pour toutes sortes
d'amélioration de notre efficacité
énergétique par exemple des programmes
pour changer portes et fenêtres pour
baisser la consommation d'énergie dans
nos maisons
donc le forez serait peut-être approprié
mais peu importe le moyen pour andré
bélisle la pollution des voitures mal
entretenus et d'un problème et il est
temps de s'y attarder
ben il n'y a pas de petits gestes liège
ou alors il faut vraiment agir de façon
responsable la santé des jeunes au poste
bas navale l'épaisseur du portefeuille
simonac ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal